corvil flug herzlich willkommen wir
heute meine damen und herren zu einem
neuen video auf einem kanal allerdings
wieder nicht alleine sondern mit
was ist heute feiertag der montag und da
ist immer das heutige video wird
übrigens wieder freundlicher weise
unterstützt von google play denn im
rahmen der player und kampagne haben die
gesagt luca sucht irgendein spiel aus
und spielt dann einfach jeden montag
[Musik]
bei dem spiel sandra du siehst es hier
schon geht es darum dass wir ein kleines
hühnchen sind und dieses hühnchen muss
einen hindernis-parcours langlaufen wir
klicke ich jetzt einfach mal auf classic
und ihr du siehst hier schon die
steuerung talking to make the chicken
walk und scream to make the chicken jam
das heißt es steuert das ding mit deiner
stimme ich muss jetzt quasi singen damit
das hühnchen läuft und ich muss schreien
damit springt ok musik jetzt mal aus und
mein allererster richtiger run kommt
jetzt alle mal es ist schon wieder das
geschafft
wie konnte es soweit kommen
mein nächster ron samra duh hat von dem
score 4
das heißt das gilt es für mich zu
schlagen ich habe im letzten spiel
geworden
stimmt doch der stadt land fluss letzte
woche auch schon gewonnen das ding ist
das spiel sieht halt so einfach aus aber
der hat er hat meinen gesang nicht
sicher ob ich meine ihr könnt euch das
spiel selbst auch unterlassen es ist
aber jetzt bin ich dran
2 ich muss doch mal besser werden als
die ist die taktik du redest erst ganz
leise und auf einmal wenn ich bringe
reißen ja okay da mach ich das jetzt
auch mal
[Musik]
3 also wie bereits gesagt da verloren
sorry von inzwischen aber sogar noch
über husten mir findet ihr oben auf
jeden fall eine info karten eingeblendet
könnt ihr irgendwie drauf klicken einem
darüber könnt ihr euch das spiel auch
runterladen oder es gibt auch einen link
unten in der infobox einer könnt ihr
euch das spiel herunterladen könnt ihr
uns ja gerne auch euren score lauten die
kommentare schreiben
das spiel ist wirklich nicht so leicht
wie man hierarchien ich würde sagen
jeder von uns macht noch eben zwei
runden und kam den anderen dann
versuchen noch mal zu sehen
ja auf jeden fall mehr auf platz eins
und geklappt hat wie zu hat alles
verändert der mitmenschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßen alle müde
direkt auf das ding drauf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der mann ist wir haben neues schicken
wir haben einen kamikaze schicken jetzt
also ich spiele jetzt bei meinem letzten
run hier mit dem kamikaze schicken das
heißt es ist für mich die letzte chance
sandra score zu knacken
ja
[Musik]
wer holz normalrunde
m
im gleichen tag einstimmen
ich bin voller schwitzen das ist
anstrengender als man denkt einen moment
ist grüne gar nicht auf sandra hoffmann
wir sind dabei mobile man es mit luca
allerdings jetzt nicht mehr meine damen
und herren denn an der stelle würden sei
noch nicht das heutige video auch
beenden wenn euch chickens spielen mit
sandra luca gefallen hat das team einen
daumen hoch unter geben genau und
anspielt das auf jeden fall auswahl
schwieriger als gedacht ja wir befinden
uns jetzt allerdings auch hier in den
karten meine lieben freunde über sandras
gesicht ist wie immer die ende
eingeblendet das heißt dass sie hat ihr
gerade das logo von chicken stimmen da
könnt ihr gern drauf klickt euch das
spiel direkt runterladen und wie bereits
gesagt uns gerne hier und in die
kommentare schreiben was euer scores das
spiel ist nicht so leicht wie man denkt
also wenn ihr mehr als 5 schafft also
besser als andere dann schreibt es gern
die kommentare und hier ist auch das
letzte video verlinkt also